i had a best friend in middle school
who at any point i think i could have
gotten horny
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen a girl who fully lost her [ __ ]
when she was in a different ap us
history class than her boyfriend
elise morales and with us today
guys we have such a fun friend he is the
host of a hot dog
on hbo max the co-host of the last
cultures podcast
a star of stage and screen a personal
friend of mine
but before all of that he was a graduate
of islip high school on long island it's
matt rogers
hello wow my buccaneer roots thank you
for bringing them to the forefront
i do always like to ask about the mascot
situation so you guys were the
buccaneers
we very much were the buccaneers which
is sort of a gayer word for pirate
um i really appreciated being a
buccaneer
um loved lo it was kind of like one of
those like great words it was like
to have spelling wise when you were
young like i can spell buccaneer it's
like saying
it's from mississippi but yeah
we were buccaneers and our colors were
gold and
purple also gay wow okay we were
burgundy and gold
that is straight versions no honestly i
feel burgundy and gold is queer also not
to sort of call
certain colors queer you know but it's
understood that purple and gold you know
you're a buccaneer not a pirate you know
what i mean well i
i do remember that there was an all-boys
school in our area and their color was
purple
or it was like purple and white and
everyone was like the all boys school is
gay and their colors are purple and it's
gay
honestly it's actually a really chic
colors i don't know like
people are just mad because not everyone
can pull it off but um it's really i
loved like
i was i was into sports when i was in
high school um so
i would i was running track i say into
sports i ran track and cross country
that's what it was um as as into sports
as that was i avoided playing with balls
and on teams at all costs
um but i loved like running in my little
like purple jersey and it was such
a gorgeous color you know what i mean
just like with the little yellow
lettering sometimes we'd have like a
like a gold outline on the jersey but it
was always like purple was like the
featured color
which i loved and my prom tie was purple
that's beautiful so okay i slipped high
school
the [ __ ] years what flavor of
high school are we talking about here
yeah so my high school was it had 270
kids in each class
okay i feel is like small town enough
where everyone knows each other
but not well enough like where everyone
knows each other well
like everyone thought they had a good
general idea of each other which is just
perfect
mwah chef's kiss for like a high school
setting
where rumors can spread about nearly
everyone
in that way where it's like the person
spreading the rumors slash gossip
thinks they are informed yeah so it's
like oh that's matt rogers
he does track is probably gay um is
funny sometimes
you know what i mean like that was sort
of like and he lives uh
south uh north of montauk which means i
wasn't rich like the rest of the kids
okay um so there's there's like that was
sort of
the deal and also like buzzings about
who was dating who
but it i wouldn't consider it like a
small small town
but it wasn't the school was certainly
not big it lived somewhere in the middle
there sports driven
i feel like at every club you know in a
similar situation where it's like the
mean girls high school was pretty much a
good approximation
actually yeah the cafeteria layout
reminded me of my cafeteria layout if
that makes any sense at all just like
the vibe
of what was happening there not
necessarily in terms of demographics i
actually thought that
tina fey's demographics were a little
weird um
but uh especially now in retrospect yeah
um but but
it was similar to that like i was like i
recognize this
as being uh mapping
for my high school well 100 100 sports
driven for sure
like the most popular kids were like the
kids that did sports
and we had a theater program but it was
like
not one that i was involved in because
it would have meant i was
gay to do it um okay so that's what i
was gonna
ask is so you were not um
you were not performing at this time no
not at all and it wasn't for lack of
wanting to in a debilitating way like i
really wanted to
so badly do the musicals and stuff and
i'm
i'm actually a very like i don't know
you've known me for years you know me to
be a very performative person
i was going to say you have a beautiful
voice thank you for saying that i
i i wanted so badly to sing in high
school in fact
like i would sort of mess around at
karaoke with my friends on the weekend
and a couple of my girlfriends were like
you really should audition you should be
in swing choir with
us your friends like but it just i got
two in my head about
um that is swing choir swing choir was
like
chorus but for people that actually were
good
anyone could join the chorus you know it
was like
if you could wake up early enough you
could join bandra chorus like maybe band
they would kick you out but chorus like
you stand there and fake singing you
know what i mean it was just kind of
like extracurricular
when a swing choir was like you had to
audition
um and i remember i even like prepared
the song that we had to sing which was
my funny valentine and then i just
i just didn't go yeah i got too anxious
yeah all right so you're doing sports at
this time
i'm getting the feeling that you are not
out
at this time absolutely not no i didn't
come out of the closet until i
till my uh summer after my freshman year
at college
so i even did an uh a year at nyu where
i was
not actually straight um yeah but um
all throughout high school it was just
too much you know
i just there was no way i could have
come out and i honestly believed that
had i come out i wouldn't have been
supported in a way where i needed to be
it wasn't a thing of like oh that's a
shame you felt like you couldn't do it
it's like no i couldn't have done it
you know i was thinking about this
recently because
i i feel like that there were kids at my
high school where everyone was like
he's gay and we all know
but i don't think that there was anyone
who was
really actively out when i was
at school and i know that we like
had a gay straight alliance and stuff
and me and all my friends like we were
like
i feel like um gay marriage was my first
like foray into politics
yeah it was like i went from being one
of those kids who said that's so gay in
middle school to being the girl in the
class who was like
it's bad to say it okay because i will
tell you
why and then like get in a fight well at
the time it was so powerful
for girls to be saying that because the
guys
cared what the girls thought and also
like
i don't know it's just like as g i said
it too
and me as a gay man was never gonna
stick up for myself
so straight guys were never gonna turn
the corner and do that because it was
too popular to be homophobic thanks
eminem
um ourselves hey guys marshall
and gay guys were never going to do it
because we were too [ __ ] afraid to be
the one to be
like i was scared in my like ap us
history and ap government class to say
that i was pro-gay marriage i used to
say i was pro-civil unions
i was like i just don't think we should
call it marriage i know well
yeah the pope moved from living in the
1500s to like 2005.
yeah that's where he's at yeah the pope
is in 2005
now um but it was important for like
girls
my contemporaries that were young ladies
to kind of step up and be like
don't do this even though it was
annoying
yeah like emo girls the powerful emo
girls really
the power that they had they didn't know
but i'm appreciative of them for
exercising the power well what was
interesting is that
i used all of my emo power on
that and i was completely uneducated on
any feminist issues and always was like
girls are mean and i actually like guys
and other girls are [ __ ] so it's very
interesting it's like i could project
progressive
thought to this other group but i didn't
have any of it reserved for myself
it's so interesting like the things that
you take on as your own opinions
because you've like you have to pick
your battles like
i decided because i couldn't be pro gay
marriage loudly in my like
social studies classes i was vehement
about abortion rights i was like this is
a
bottom liner for me that we cannot be
telling women what to do with their
bodies i don't care what it is like
i was like very vocal about it and
actually earned the moniker
of very liberal from my teacher he's
like you're the most liberal person in
the class and i was like god damn right
i am and i'm not even being honest and
passionate about the one that i [ __ ]
need so i mean it's such a flip because
i i mean i don't think i feel like if
you had asked teen elise she would have
been like yeah
abortions were supposed to have those
but also it's like i get why people
don't want to have that like
but so it's it's so interesting that as
as
teenagers it's like you have com you can
be compassionate out but you're not
ready to like do it inward for yourself
100 do you feel like because you're
obviously
one of lost culturists i am one of them
uh do you feel like pop culture
influenced your politics and whatnot
because i know for me
it was being into like punk and emo
music
at the time that was all like [ __ ] bush
the iraq war is bad like
that made me be like okay it's actually
[ __ ] cool to be political and i agree
with this and now
like i'm a politics girl yeah
100 i mean for me very similarly
what i was absorbing that i truly loved
was like the comedy of margaret cho
and past guest on the show oh
we just had her and she was the best
she's
she's an icon for sure we've had around
lost cultures too yes
she's something um but she was hugely
formative for me
and i remember all of her stand-up
albums i just would
listen to them and even though i didn't
get a lot of it explicitly like i didn't
know what a colonic
was you know what i mean like i didn't
get
like why the movie beaches was funny for
her to do like a riff about how gay it
is
but i did inherently there was something
in it that i
identified and um she was extremely
liberal
yeah and i was just like yeah you know
what you're right
like why don't why aren't we able to get
married
like i don't understand like what is the
big [ __ ] deal like i know in my heart
i wasn't like
made incorrectly so what's going on why
it really scared me as someone who saw
like a nuclear family
as a thing to aspire to um i really
felt like you know this would be
unattainable for me and she was pointing
out the injustice in that
on the flip side there was like i
mentioned before
like very popularly there was eminem
like he was the biggest mainstream
pop star which is what he was because he
was making popular music like i know he
was a rap artist
um but he was on pop radio so he was the
biggest pop star at the time maybe him
and like britney spears
and so and she had no politics
so but his like views on
gays and on women like really deeply
sickened me
but i still bought the eminem show
because everyone had it
and so have we talked about this like i
remember like
my favorite thing when i would buy cds
was i would look through the packaging
like i would read the lyrics and
everything and that packaging for the m
eminem show was like
him just having murdered his audience
like it was like a sh
he was just like shot up his audience
basically
yeah and there was photos of them all
dead and it was like clear that he did
it
and i was just like this has upset me
and hurt me in such a deep
dark way and i'm so sad that this is
mainstream
and millions of people went out and
bought this
and no one's talking about the fact that
this is like
violent and hurtful and really crazy
um ah it's it's really interesting
because
i bought the eminem show and i like
liked it like when i was in middle
school and stuff i was like eminem's
funny and he like
talks about your butt and stuff and like
and then i remember my parents have
um just a good friend who's gay and he
was visiting over the house and i
mentioned liking eminem
and he said to me like uh well you know
not all the stuff that he says is
good and it was like it was the first
time
anyone had ever checked me like and i
had and i was like a kid and i was like
oh
well and it was the first time that i
kind of made the connection of like
no these lyrics are harmful and they
hurt
my friend and they hurt my dad's friend
and now and it like
changed my ability to be into the album
and to be into him at all because i
thought he was like cute
and like well he was hot is the thing
too that's another part of it like
another part of it that no one talks
about is eminem is really cute and has
like a [ __ ]
rockin ass and so for me as like a
true little homo it was this and there
were these he would love to take
pictures shirtless and like
a lot of my like friends that were
straight would have pictures of eminem
on their wall and you can see like his
very red nipple and stuff and i was just
like i'm so
deeply horny for eminem he hates me so
much um based on what he says yeah
and it's frustrating and um
like dark for me let's look through some
of these
photos that you i guess because oh
my god okay okay can i say something i
looked good
first of all i'm gonna say you look good
second of all i'm gonna say
you're you're doing the straight thing
and you're doing it well
honestly okay so this is where i reveal
some stuff
this was a quote unquote white trash
party
if you can believe it and that's why
i've got this sort of like
what we called wife beaters at the time
we know to call them tank tops now
i remember the first time also that i
was like oh
that's not good literally at least like
last year i was looking at i was like
you know this like wife beater and i
heard the words come out of my mouth and
i'm like oh
my god we were calling it a wife
beater anyway um yes this is a white
trash party
um i was at i think that um i really
never wore hats all my girlfriends told
me i i
looked bad in hats so this was huge to
have the excuse the girl in this picture
i won't say her name but
we used to sort of make out every now
and then um
there was like some up and down with us
and i actually genuinely was attracted
to her in high school and couldn't
figure out why
come to find out she's uh absolutely
mage lesbian
this makes a ton of sense and we
actually both went to nyu
you mutually bearded for each other
well we never officially dated but we
always had like a connection
and i never understood it i was like why
of all the girls here am i attracted
more at all to this one than everyone
else
and then i realized later it's like i
don't know what it was it was like a
cosmic connection that we had
yes um but yeah this was and of course
you can see beer pong in the back
i was gonna say the setup is of that you
can see in the back
is such a classic high school
house party scenario so is this a parent
who's
out of town that we're looking at this
is actually
my friend val's house and she her mom
was kind of out of sight out of mind
about the whole thing i think she was
not around that night she might have
been out doing something but
this was like one of the houses where we
could go like
very um if you're going to drink it
rather you do it in the house energy
yes but so my parents were certainly not
like that so this was a big night but
usually like
someone's parents would be gone
or out of town or out of the house for a
certain amount of time on
any given weekend but this yeah this one
just so happened to be
uh a night at val's and we're playing
beer pong
in the back there that's my best friend
in high school his name was kenny
um and that table racked up
he went to udel hell yeah
which is where i met you yeah so i that
that weekend that i was in udell and i
we were there doing a comedy festival i
guess like
your improv troupe was hosting it that i
was actually
half also there to go hang out with him
and all my friends and
he was my best friend in high school and
also my unrequited love of my life
um so was that going on at this
point like were you oh deeply in love
with him at this point deeply
um but he's he's like the best person
ever
and like um was so cool when i
came out of the closet and like it was
not even a thing like love me just the
same
we had some ups and downs when i felt
when i feel like he thought i was like
not being honest with him
but it's hard like i remember thinking
to myself at that time like
if i tell anyone and they're not cool
with it it's fine but he has to be cool
with it
like that was where i was at um it would
have crushed me
had he like rejected me at that point
but he did not
and he is um a beautiful man still to
this day
he's got a little baby named amelia he's
married to erica who he's been dating
since um
i think they were like freshman in high
school i actually like kind of played a
role in getting them together
well there you go i used to sit in the
room with them while they'd hook up
behind me i'd be on facebook on the
computer and they'd be in the back when
cooking up and i would just be like
the most sick mix of like
devastated and like pleased to be there
hello everyone today's episode of the
roast of your teenage self podcast
is brought to you by candid
just like imagine that my my teeth like
i did a smile and then there was
i start you get it it's like a cartoon
thing you know all the things that we'd
love to do for ourselves but haven't
done for whatever reason
for me i always wanted straighter
teeth and a better smile it's one of
those things
when you get involved in hollywood
they're like
are you gonna buy new teeth are you
gonna buy all new teeth and then they're
kind of weirdly too perfect and they're
not really
your teeth no you don't have to do that
you don't have to get weird teeth and
i'm done putting
off making my regular normal teeth
look straighter thanks dee candid
straightening my teeth
is simpler easier and more comfortable
than ever
candid clear aligners are comfortable
removable and practically
invisible unlike wire braces
or crazy weird fake ceramic teeth
so you can transform your smile without
anyone noticing plus
your treatment is prescribed and
monitored by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement and it's all done
from the comfort and convenience of your
own home
i know when i was getting started i was
like am i gonna have to go see
some random orthodontist i don't really
want to have to do that i'm trying to
not leave my house that much
but no candid only works with
orthodontists
never dentists like other companies
plus your supervising orthodontist will
be with you every step of the way
again virtually so you don't have to
leave your home
with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring by the same
orthodontist who created your plan
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing you'll always know
i love that and the average candid
treatment is only six months and you'll
start seeing results
way before then and it costs thousands
less than braces start straightening
your teeth today
right now all of my listeners can save
on candid starter kit go to candid
co.com
slash teen self and use code team self
that's candidco.com teen self
code team self take advantage of this
limited time offer to save
seventy five dollars on your starter kit
candid
co dot com slash teen cell code
team so you got it i said it enough
times you that you guys
know what up y'all today's episode of
the roast of your teenage self podcast
is brought to you by magic spoon
we've talked on this podcast about how
in high school every morning for
breakfast
i would drink a full sugar coke from the
vending machine
and then wonder why i felt extremely bad
all day long well this year i have been
trying to develop
better breakfasting habits and i can do
that
in the most delicious way possible
thanks to magic spoon magic spoon
is zero sugar 11 grams of protein and
only
three net grams of carbs in each serving
so you can start your day out
with something sweet and something tasty
just like when you were a teen
but without ripping a hole in your
stomach first thing in the morning
with a full sugar coke from the vending
machine
magic spoon comes with four flavors
cocoa
fruity frosted and blueberry it tastes
amazing and like
i'm not i'm not saying that it tastes
amazing and it doesn't really taste
amazing and i'm just saying that because
they're sponsoring the show
magic spoon is really good it genuinely
tastes extremely good
i have become a serial person
because of magic spoon in a way that
even
the sugary cereals of our past have
never done for me
because those made me make me feel
guilty when i'm an adult and i feel
bad and i'm like i shouldn't have eaten
that but not
with magic spoon okay magic spoon is
keto friendly gluten-free grain free
soy free low carb and gmo
free i got the variety pack so i got one
of each of the flavors
i have finished cocoa i have finished
blueberry
they came less than a week ago so
i'm gonna need to be getting myself
another variety pack soon i
cannot personally review fruity and
frosted yet
but if they are as good as cocoa and
blueberry
i will be done with magic spoon by the
end of the week so go to
magicspoon.com roast to grab a variety
pack
and try today and be sure to use our
promo code roast
at checkout to get free shipping and
magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
by a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason
they'll refund you your money no
questions asked you don't have to send
them back
the cereal they specifically told me
that on the phone when i talked to them
they were like please don't
send us half-eaten boxes of cereal it's
fine we'll refund you your money
we don't need your unopened cereal now
so
to get your magic spoon which you won't
be returning for any reason because it
is delicious
that's magicspoon.com roast and use the
code roast for
free shipping and we thank magic spoons
so much for sponsoring at the podcast
now i'm italian
okay let's go through some more of these
photos because they're they're really
stunning
this is a huge deal so this was at a
track
camp so this was the second track camp
that i ever went to because the first
track camp i went to
a girl showed me attention and i got so
nervous about how it would progress that
i had an anxiety attack
a full panic attack and got extremely
sick because of it and had to leave the
camp oh my god
so oh yeah so i i there's it's a very
long story that involves like a
milkshake
dance social that like i sort of grinded
with her
like the social and then everyone
thought oh that now
tomorrow night you guys will probably
make out and i was like so
panicked about that that i completely
had a meltdown
and years later i would reconnect with
that girl at a random oar
concert i swear to god um
the social pressure around grinding in
general
like i remember like when i had to go to
a dance and like i
literally practiced kind of grinding in
the mirror to be like am i doing this
right like you can't really do it wrong
it's just allowing
someone to rub up on you it's really as
kind of weird as it sounds
yeah it's like well all the dances we
went to were literally
children rubbing their genitals on each
other and that was the
whole dance and now when i go out
dancing
i mean maybe i'll grind a little bit but
for the most part i'm like
i'm just not doing that at all yeah no
i just i don't care at all i'd rather be
by myself so i can like
perform yeah um but this was the track
camp that i made it through so this was
the
end of the week at track camp this is me
and
all the girls from east islip high
school so i was the only person from
iceland high school there
because i was the only one who took
track seriously enough
and so all these girls were from east
islip and i sort of
knew them just from the track scene and
um
i also have supplied you with we took
this picture this was the last day of
camp
and then they all wanted pictures with
me individually
okay so yep that was me and cassandra
who i actually went on a date with and
um that it didn't happen but um she
actually was cute
um oh my god and so this next one i
forget her name but she was
i think her name was chelsea she was
sort of she was sort of having fun with
the picture
yeah and i do want to say that all of
these pictures
each of these girls represents a very
specific
early 2000s track girl style
yeah and they're also like they they
would all grow up to be really good
co-hosts on the view
yeah like there are there's such a good
demographically like specific
yes like cross-section of girls
like this particular type of abercrombie
like it's not like an empire top
yep how uncomfortable i am being hugged
in my track jacket that says rogers
look at me her she's hugging like around
my
arm which is taped to my side
yes the your like the bottom half of
your bodies could not be further apart
oh i know i don't know do i get more
comfortable let's see
looks like it was most comfortable yeah
like that's you know there's something
there
with me in this blonde girl and here's
another one of the tops
with the with the cami lace like what do
you call this top
see it's not a it's not a cami because
the cami is more
fitted on the bottom but you know it's
like a maternity
shirt it's a maternity really like
it's like either a young young young
baby toddler's dress
or a maternity gown like it looks like
um like a christening
dress yes if it were just a little bit
longer
like you know it's like nicole kidman's
wearing it in the beguiled
you know what i mean absolutely
absolutely i i'm letting her kind of get
some
waste there yeah my hand is on the
shoulder i think me and this girl were
more friendly
absolutely but let's see okay so now see
me and steph this is steph we were
like we didn't have a romantic thing but
we had a connection
mm-hmm and as so so you can see
i'm letting her get like we're we're
having full body contact here and i'm
holding my hat as a sign of respect
so do you feel like when as like
as a young queer boy you're having these
like
were these connections that you made
with other girls often
confused with like oh maybe this is my
girlfriend
or sometimes but for some reason
these girls like all these girls they
didn't scare me they were my
friends i think that um like because
there were so many of them
like it wasn't like we only had like a
few days to get to know each other so i
would just sit with them at lunch and
talk and
it was cool you know it wasn't this
thing of like they were trying to push
one of them towards me
but that first girl cassandra she wasn't
really in this group she kind of just
came over for the picture
and she did kind of there was some um
there was some stuff going on
i actually had a boyfriend at the camp
who i thought was so hot his name was
john
he was always shirtless and like that
sort of like really skinny but
ripped shirtless track boy like running
around in his little track shorts
truly truly truly crazy who was like
your
celebrity crush at this time
dude i'll tell you it was deeply and so
the first person i ever remember being
attracted to and getting angry about it
and i didn't know why
was justin timberlake when i was in
fourth or fifth grade like i saw him in
like the tearing up my heart video
with the right not wife beater with the
white tank top
like sitting kind of like this with his
hand with his like
sort of like lounging on that like bed
and he was very sexually filmed
and i was like all the girls at my
school were obsessed with him
yes they knew why but i didn't know why
and i was like i hate justin timberlake
i [ __ ] hate justin timberlake and
they're like wow
why do you hate him so much and i'm like
i just hate him and i really it was it
was
out of a deep deep desire
to um you know put my mouth on him
uh i mean even when he had the like
ramen hair
did it matter it didn't matter i'll say
this it doesn't matter to this day
he could do the whole man out of the man
of the woods arrow which was such
[ __ ] like i'll still
open it up for jt anytime the hair
that young boys had when we were in our
oh a low point in the history of hair oh
i had such a crush on this boy
lucas whose stepbrother was in eve six
and we both
sat in the very back of like
he had an m last name and so we both sat
in like
everyone had desks that were in big
squares except
us too had two solo desks in the back of
the classroom and i was like
this is the most romantic thing that has
cosmic
i was like this truly like my this
the lord i went to a christian
elementary school i was like the lord
has intervened
and put lucas and i together and he had
this
involved the flip you know the like the
heart it was bleached thank you
so basically i have to say i
did the flip for sure i
knew i knew new new and was even saying
at the time
this bleach tip thing is not going to
age
well not right this is going to be over
in 12 months
to 18 months and we are going to be
humiliated that we did it so i never did
that i did highlight my hair in 10th
grade oh
well let's take a look at the hair
claudia our producer has independence
[Laughter]
claudia is actually roasting that at
this point pulling up
a very spiked hair moment i mean
everything about this is bad that's like
it's like
this hair is like it looks like it's
trying to be sideshow bob but i have pin
straight hair
like i don't know what is going on like
i guess i tried to rough it up and it
ended up being this
flop i'm getting derrick wybley from
some 41. oh my god that's
kind the ex-husband of miss avril
lavigne
of course oh yeah i have to say also
behind me in this photo is this kid
jimmy who dated my friend emily who i
also had such a crush on and he is i
think doing a [ __ ] motion behind me
here which is classic
classic humor of the time i also do want
to point out my
popped collar over
a ringer tee with you guessed it
a necklace
[Laughter]
beaded necklace now the girl that you're
with has on
a lay are we at another themed party
you bet your bottom dollar we're at a
sweet 16 here we're at the sweet 16 of
my friend alex dorsam
uh who was my girlfriend in high school
was my first kiss emmy went to prom
together the year i won
senior prom king oh my god
that's beautiful and she had here like a
luau themed sweet 16. so i have to tell
you
i came into high school with no friends
like most annoying identity confused
like
mess left high school being senior prom
king so i did
and i was nominated for homecoming king
and junior prom king so i was like
amy adams glenn close overdue
so but you got it at the end and you got
it i
got it i got it i mean even even though
there's rumors that was fixed
i got it okay well some rumors
there's some rumors that my friend
brittany actually
who since passed it's very sad but
there's some rumors that she rigged it
for me and my friend jackie um
well then goodbye i can't confirm and
she's she's no longer with us through
confirmers and eyes so
it's actually respectful for that to
remain it's yeah it's actually would be
best if we didn't speak on it because
it's respectable to her memory
okay so speaking of proms yeah this is
me
at my junior prom this is me with the
daughter of the art teacher
beautiful this is me with christa
we did not go to promise together but we
were friends because i was of course
that kid in high school who was very
close to some teachers
so i was very close to ms knoblach who
was get
this my art teacher my track coach
and my class advisor wow
she also in her life had been a new york
city police officer
a marathon runner lover of the arts she
actually exposed us all to aretha
franklin
and big old republican at the time
so she truly contained multitudes i
don't know where she stands now on all
of this
but i remember having like weird like
disagreements with her about politics
and i was like but you're
but you're but you're you yeah i mean it
made no sense to me
so this was me and her daughter christa
and
i loved krista she she was at the prom
because you know
she was just her mom was my class
advisor she was like throwing it
so she came we took this fun picture
together of i guess like a charlie's
angels pose which is yeah
charlie classic so that night i did lose
junior
prom king but i did win this photo
absolutely do you remember the prom your
prom
themes girl you know it was under the
sea
oh my god i wanted nothing more than an
underdog you know it was under the sea
and you know we had the other one was
old hollywood
those are two only themes ours was just
forever young yeah forever young
city always makes a joke that she's like
it's either under the sierra parisian
knights
they just did forever young or hollywood
yeah and i was like
but that's not even really a theme
that's just ever young
that's honestly though it kind of takes
the pressure off
yeah and you know what i will say i did
wear purple
when my date told me she was wearing a
purple gown i was
i was truly excited also i'm telling you
right now i would truly kill for my
waist in this picture now you i mean
it's like
you're doing like a blue steel energy as
well that was my whole
vibe i i i so desperately wanted to
capitalize on my like
facial gift i thought i had at that
point i thought i was so hot
well you're being approached by
abercrombie people matt
yeah i was like i was like it's a shame
sexually no one can come
use this because uh all i want to do is
be used
god i would have oh my god i can't even
tell you i wanted to [ __ ] every boy at
my high school it was so stuck
did you ever have like sparks fly with
another
boy or were you not even able to like
put
i'll say this i had a
best friend in middle school who
at any point i think it could have
gotten horny like we
he would come over and we would have
sleepovers we would like look at each
other's abs and like touch
each other's like like physiques like
just to be like
i need to work on this like i need to do
more push-ups on this this this this
and talk about girls like eating out
girls and it was just so
horny and i was i was aware i was gay at
that point but wasn't telling anyone
i was just i don't know we used to our
favorite song was the song picture by
kid rock and shell crow
it was just like a lot of like fringe
gay stuff like it could have gotten sexy
at any point and i swear to god
i wish it had and then there was like
the oft
like aim conversation i would have with
someone from another town
you know what i mean like um and i
found out about a couple kids that were
gay in high school
that i found out after the fact one of
which i did make out with at a bar on
christmas break
um his name was so you were able to do
some retroactive work
on the breaks which is really all that
thanksgiving and christmas break when
you're in college are about
it's like who did i not [ __ ]
with that i should have oh man
i wish we had had sex honestly all we
did was like make out and like really
fill each other up outside of this bar
but honestly it's so crazy because
10 years later like 2018 if we were in
high school together we would have been
so the gay power couple i do think it
would have been okay to come out at that
point yes
i think i remember i'm
senior well yeah now like what my little
cousin
now carol baskin is bi so yeah exactly
exactly they're all gay now
everyone's gay um but i do remember my
senior year
there was a boy on the cheerleading team
and he was openly gay
and that was like the first kid i
remember at my school
being openly gay and i think he had a
tough
time doing that i think i think he
walked a hard road with that one
yeah it just the er you graduated in
2008 high school
yeah so this was not the era of like no
you know there wasn't even the
i would i honestly at the time when we
were in high school
i remember when obama like started to
become a thing i was like there's no way
there's no way like change was not in
the air when i was on long island and
then all of a sudden i moved to new york
and it was so exciting that people were
ready to welcome
new possibilities for leadership and you
know i remember
when there started to be more gay shows
on television like
discovering drag race i was like what is
this like
i just wasn't exposed to it in high
school because another thing is
the reason why it was so terrifying at
the time to come out which is why it's
so much easier now i would imagine
probably still hard but there were just
no examples of yourself in the media
like i couldn't see my future no one was
out there living it we had like
will and grace where like will was the
straight acting one who was acceptable
socially and then there was jack who was
like a fop
and a joke and also kind of will and
grace and we're like are will and grace
gonna get together like what is
this and then they had they had that
weird plotline where it was like they
were trying to get pregnant and they
were gonna actually [ __ ]
i was like they don't want to do this
this is trauma
yeah like it's not necessary
um so let's talk about how did you
decide to go to nyu like you're if
how did you what was your journey to go
to nyu and what was your journey to
actually starting to become a performer
at nyu
so to be honest with you like when i was
applying to schools i told my parents i
was like i only want to apply to new
york city schools or local schools
because i was still
i was a very anxious kid actually um i
did
i am very extroverted now and i i
come conversation is like a trade for me
now i've gotten more comfortable with
myself but it took a very
long time for me to be able to
comfortably engage in conversation with
like really any new person
um so i wasn't super excited about
moving away from home um but i thought i
definitely want an experience where i
can get away enough or i can try to
explore
the fact that i'm gay because i want to
hook up with a boy so bad
yeah um so i was like new york city it's
perfect
we'll do this i applied early decision
to colombia actually got like
the stamp of approval from the athletics
department i was going to be a d1
cross-country athlete at
columbia but obviously didn't get into
columbia on academics
so i then got into nyu
and i think my parents could tell like
he really wants to go there and it was
super expensive like exorbitantly so but
they did
they did um allow me to go what sucked
is
that girl in the first picture also got
into the nyu
so i thought to myself oh [ __ ] she's
going to want to hang out all the time
i'm not going to be able to come out
after all
because she's going to tell everyone at
home that i'm gay
like she was becoming more comfortable
with her identity she had like come out
senior year like she decided she was
gonna be like a lesbian at nyu
and i wasn't there and i thought oh
she's gonna like expose me to all my
friends at home
um needless to say i did go to nyu
realized it was [ __ ] huge i never saw
her at all
but i did let that fear rule me all
freshman year so i didn't do
anything i wanted to do sophomore year i
internal transferred into tisch
which is the art school at nyu and then
i started writing i was in the dramatic
writing program that's when i met stewie
that's when i started to become friends
with bowen
and i i wheeled myself into the sketch
comedy group at the time despite having
no
performance experience i was just like i
know i'm supposed to do this
yeah so i just like
by the grace of god like crushed my
audition for them
like what became obsessed with all
things culturally
new york comedy like i was like taking
ucb classes
and waiting on the standby line at snl
every weekend
that's insane i mean i didn't make
friends
freshman year i was like at the standby
line until i eventually got into a
sketch comedy group and made friends
almost every week for i was like out
there for the snl standby which is why
it's
so [ __ ] insane what has transpired i
know
um
like the star of it i actually tested
for it twice
they called me back to they they kept me
on hold i really thought i had a chance
it didn't work out which is totally fine
totally fine right
um it was wild for so long it's like
that's such an incredible crazy journey
it was a dream come true because my
entire i i just couldn't
believe that it was happening like my
entire existence
all throughout my 20s i i'll be really
real so i was like
really depressed my freshman year like i
remember i went i i was like trying to
make friends it wasn't happening
there was a day where i didn't get into
the standby line because there's no
guarantees and i had sat out in the cold
for like hours and hours and hours
i think it was the paul rudd and beyonce
episode which ended up being like an
iconic episode where she did like a
single ladies sketch and justin
timberlake was there it was like so
cool and i didn't get it and i sat on my
bed and i just started
crying and crying crying and i was like
i know
that i'm like a valid person
like i know it i can't be this sad all
the time so i
literally got on my laptop and i googled
the person that i admired most in the
world
and it was amy poehler and so i typed in
amy poehler and like
saw ucb and like read all about how she
got to where she was
and then i literally just like
essentially tried to copy her
i was like okay i have to get into my
comedy group after college
i have to take classes at this place
upright citizens brigade i have to like
start now like because she started in
college so i have to start in college
i'm already behind
people have been doing improv since high
school like what am i doing like we
didn't even have that
like i just made it my mission and i'm
telling you i
willed myself to be in these positions
where i could just
maybe try to prove i had some talent and
then luckily i did
so and it took me all the way to where i
almost got on that
show and i didn't which was hard
yeah but ultimately now looking back i'm
so happy everything's worked out the way
that it has
and it's just like truly it feels like
the bookends of my experience of my 20s
that was very sort of defined by
the like trauma of being a closeted gay
kid like
i'm so pleased with it i really am
that's
so beautiful and that's such a perfect
place for me to ask you
our final question uh so
i feel like i could we could chat
forever but i know
okay if you could talk to teen matt
today what would you tell him
oh my gosh well i would tell him that he
was
dead on about pretty much that bleached
hairstyle
just so you know you are slaying
um with this opinion um i would tell him
that he is funny
that he that he doesn't have to worry as
much and that he's going to be
really happy and that he doesn't have to
worry about that that much wow that
makes me really emotional
because i was such a sad kid um and i
would also tell him that i would i would
i would tell him to do the things he
wants to do i would say
you know no it's not going to matter in
a decade what anyone had to say about
you
auditioning for the swing choir matt
yeah you like singing and you're a good
singer so
you should you should be in the swing
choir it'll make you happy and it'll
make the swing choir better
yeah and you could be on red birdie
i know and i wish i could just tell
myself to get out of my own way because
ultimately in the grand scheme i didn't
spend that much time
but you know the world is so cruel
to people that don't fit into it uh on
face value
and so like now my heart is going out to
you know the the people i think that are
the most persecuted which are trans
people
like there's it seems like there's still
this dragging of the feet to sort of
be like no trans women are women trans
men are men like
trans lives are valid like we
like trans lives matter like if they're
just like hit at your school
let them use the bathroom that they want
to use so they don't have to be
harassed and hold holding their pee all
day because they're scared
like yeah i just wish that we could be
more compassionate
um in terms of just just like human to
human
what we all need and what we all want
which is to be happy and comfortable and
safe and to be able to be in an
environment where you can learn
and grow and show who you are and share
that with people
and i feel like we um unfortunately
live in a world that i thought was
improving in that way
um and then the last few years have been
very difficult to see
um how that's not true um
but you know it's uh i just hope that
the world gets kinder and i hope that
people are kinder to themselves and so
that's what i would tell myself i would
just say
just be so much nicer to yourself
because you are literally not a freak
like one day boy
i was i you know it just
yeah it just it just was so um it was so
hard to exist
and now i'm like i just wish i could
tell i wish i could tell
myself with that age how successful i
was going to be and that how happy i was
going to be and that
literally the thing i hate about myself
is gonna be my superpower yeah and it is
gonna be
like what um
not what people like about me but so
much of what unlocks
like who i really am and what why people
like me so
yeah yeah matt that's so beautiful
this has been such an amazing time wow
i have to say elise like what a great
progression of this show
like i'm so happy that you decided to do
it as a podcast because
it really i i said this many times when
i was in new york but your show was
it was one of my top three favorite
shows in new york that i ever did i had
such a fun time doing it that night
you've really turned it into something
yeah just valid and not really really
nice inspiring so yeah thank you so much
and to everyone listening at home this
has been the roast of your teenage self
podcast
[Music]
you